A Rush of panic as people flee after
hearing
gunfire at prague's Charles University
the site of the shooting police sealed
off the surrounding area and ordered
people to go indoors in the beginning
there was couple of uh uh Banks I didn't
even realize it's a it's a shooting then
uh suddenly there were students and
teachers running out of uh
uh out of the building of the of the
philosophical faculty this is the man
who's been identified as a sole
perpetrator 24-year-old student David
kak who attended the same University
where he conducted his shooting spree
and died at the scene possibly by
Suicide according to the interior
Minister his father had also been found
dead earlier in the day and this is
where he struck the fourth floor of the
University's faculty of philosophy in a
desperate attempt to escape students
climbed out of the windows and perched
on the
[Music]
ledge one student was reported to have
lost her grip and fell to her death
before embarking on his deadly Rampage
coac left a series of disturbing
messages on social media describing how
he wanted to commit mass murders adding
to the shock in a country where such
mass shootings are extremely rare Sonia
Gago alaz
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al
jazer